voilà messieurs bonsoir bienvenue au 20
heures le trafic aérien à orly ouest
restera perturbé jusqu'à demain la grève
air france a été de nouveau reconduite
aujourd'hui les candidats au départ ont
dû faire preuve de patience près d'un
vol sur trois a été annulé la
catastrophe a été évitée de justesse à
noisy-le-sec en seine-saint-denis un
immeuble hlm s'est effondré à la suite
d'une explosion due au gaz
c'est une canalisation qui a été percée
par des travaux sur la voie publique
heureusement le bâtiment a pu être
évacués à temps poignant et troublant en
grande bretagne les parents de maddie
ont lancé aujourd'hui à un message de
noël leur petite fille disparue on peut
y voir des archives du réveillon avec
l'enfant le dernier c'était quelques
mois avant qu'elles ne disparaissent
lors de vacances au portugal
le père noël est en rupture de stock à
deux jours du réveillon certains jouets
phare demandé par les enfants ne sont
déjà plus disponible
unis dans les hautes ni dans les
magasins il se dirige à grands pas vers
mars à 13 kilomètres par seconde un
énorme astéroïde pourrait selon la nasa
percuté la planète rouge le 30 janvier
prochain
si cela devait arriver il creuserait
alors un cratère de près d'un kilomètre
de diamètre
on commence avec la grève air france
elle se poursuivra demain à orly-ouest
s'ils en ont décidé les salariés
aujourd'hui
autant dire que la pression monte pour
les parisiens qui ont choisi l'avion
pour rejoindre leur famille à noël
reportage caroline thébaux yanhel
anglade avec une mère des plantes qui
n'ont marché
alors aujourd'hui sans me dire qu'ils
marchent pas mafalda il se trouvait
depuis une dizaine de vols annulés sur
nice strasbourg toulouse bordeaux et
surtout incompréhension et manque
d'information alors que le temps presse
vous passez dix minutes sur les sites
internet pour vérifier que ça fonctionne
on dit oui sur les sites payants ont dit
oui vous vous pointez ici il ya une dame
à l'accueil qui vous explique
benoîtement havane ont accusés nous vol
est annulé
pas d'annulation mais beaucoup beaucoup
de retard pour cette famille nombreuse
le vol qui devait partir à 14h25 et
toujours pas parti on aura des nouvelles
à 17 heures on sait pas si d'école à 17
heures les enfants commence à avoir faim
ces perturbations devraient durer au
moins jusqu'à 15 heures demain le
personnel au sol a reconduit la lie
quand on a des salaires d'embauché 1190
euros bruts net en dessous de 1000 euros
on ne peut pas s'étonner que dans une
entreprise qui fait autant d'argent
et bien il y ait de revendications qui
pousse huit vols sur dix devraient quand
même être assurée demain affirme la
direction
qui dit ne pas comprendre ce mouvement
il n'y a que deux syndicats sur sept qui
ont appelé à cette grève
essentiellement du personnel piste alors
que on a annoncé avant le mouvement que
des négociations salariales allait
s'ouvrir le 22 janvier
la compagnie assure que les vols annulés
seront intégralement remboursés
un terrible incendie s'est déclaré la
nuit dernière à pointe à pitre en
guadeloupe
le dernier bilan est de six morts et un
blessé grave à l'origine du drame un jeu
stupide des enfants qui ont envoyé un
pétard dans un magasin le feu s'est
alors rapidement propagé il n'a pu être
éteint qu'après neuf heures
d'intervention des pompiers philippe
rochot
la fumée recouvrait encore pointe à
pitre 9 heures après le début de la
tragédie
le magasin n'avait pas d'issue de
secours l'incendié n'a laissé aucune
chance aux six personnes bloquées à
l'intérieur les pompiers eux-mêmes ont
hésité longtemps avant de pénétrer dans
ce brasier a été durement touchée par
l'incendié menace ruine
il ya des risques d'effondrement et donc
il nous faut être extrêmement prudent
dans l'engagement de nos personnages
le magasin était en fête à bazar tenus
par des chinois qui vendait des produits
d'asie en ces veilles de fêtes il avait
stocké beaucoup de pétards pour saluer
l'arrivée de noël et du nouvel an des
enfants se sont pris au jeu et aurait
allumé leurs pétards à l'intérieur du
magasin les maires ont dores et déjà
pris les arrêtés sur l'agglomération de
pointe-à-pitre interdisant la vente des
pétards aux mineurs et bien entendu
c'est cet événement cette affaire sera
l'occasion de regarder à nouveau les
condition bien entendu de vente par les
commerçants de ses pétales une enquête
est bien sur un court
six morts au dernier bilan parmi les
clients et les familles habitant
l'immeuble
pointe à pitre à la guadeloupe seront en
deuil pour les fêtes de noël et du
nouvel an c'est la deuxième fois en deux
mois en seine-saint-denis une fuite de
gaz a provoqué l'effondrement d'un
immeuble à noisy le sec
heureusement il a pu être évacué
attendre compte donc cinq blessés légers
mais comme a bondi le mois dernier c'est
une canalisation de gaz qui a été
endommagé par des travaux sur la voie
publique
fanny stenneler r david fossard 38
appartements touchés dont 20 entièrement
détruit la barre d'immeuble a été
éventrée coupée en deux par l'explosion
tôt ce matin le gardien de l'immeuble
sans une forte odeur de gaz
il lance alerte dans tous les
appartements parmi la centaine
d'habitants certains se précipitent dans
la rue
d'autres sont évacués par les secours un
miracle que tous s'en soit sorti indemne
si à dépenser car un petit noël
tranquille qui avait acheté sa
trottinette qui restait leur ma chambre
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être rien mais
pour mousser ses énormes quoi voilà ce
que j'ai sorti de chez moi de 35 ans de
vie dans ma maison tout est permis
vivement d'après gaz de france ce sont
des travaux sur la voirie qui aurait
endommagé la canalisation la mairie
arrive aux mêmes conclusions
malencontreusement certainement lors des
forages
on a touché une canalisation de gaz
et ça a été donc l'explosion enfin
d'abord la fuit depuis l'explosion
ce soir 250 personnes ne dormiront pas
chez elle une partie s'est installé dans
un gymnase de la ville
les hôtes pourront choisir d'aller dans
une des 70 chambres d'hôtel réservées
dans le département tous les membres de
l'arche de zoé ont pu être entendu par
les juges tchadien est déjà au deuxième
jour du procès on constate une scission
claire entre les français d'un côté et
l'intermédiaire sudan et de l'autre ce
dernier aujourd'hui a reconnu qu'il
avait menti sur l'origine des enfants
qui ne venaient pas en réalité du
darfour en revanche il a affirmé qu'ils
ne savaient pas qu'ils devaient être
envoyés en france
envoyés spéciaux n'djamena amaury
guibert frédéric ranque
en arrivant au palais de justice d'une
djamena eric breteau et emilie lelouch
ont tout de suite voulu recentrer les
débats
vous allez voir les enfants de
allez voir les enfants devient les 103
enfants ont été au centre de l'audience
d'aujourd'hui
l'arche de zoé pouvait-elle savoir
qu'aucun n'était orphelin que la
quasi-totalité venait de village
tchadien à la barre emilie lelouch a
raconté sa version des faits peut-être
avons-nous été bernés confesse-t-elle
sous-entendu par des intermédiaires
locaux
aujourd'hui on a une impression déjà par
un peu fière de pâques on m'a fait les
mêmes en vérité qu'on a apporté de
questions quant à l'évoquer qui n'ont
peut-être pas de réponse car la défense
a pressé de questions cet homme
souleymane ibrahim adam un intermédiaire
soudanais qui a mené 63 ans à l'époque
il avait signé des attestation
certifiant qu'ils étaient orphelins du
darfour mais à la barre c'est tout le
contraire
il reconnaît qu'il savait que les
enfants étaient de châtier où est la
vérité comment je dis comment on peut
mon en comptant les déclarations
d'intérêts voilà c'est ça
malheureusement j'ai l'impression que
les juges ne cherche pas à creuser
mais pour les parties civiles l'enjeu du
procès est très loin de ces questions de
nationalité qu'il y mensonge ou pas est
ce que eric berthaud est habilité à 63
gosses du territoire tchadien
je me bats ma question c'est c'est ça
qui m'intéressait mais à la fin de
l'audience certains des accusés comme
emilie lelouch apparaissait plus
souriant au delà de la nationalité des
enfants ou du rôle des intermédiaires
eric breteau et les autres membres de
l'arche de zoé tiennent à rappeler dès
qu'ils le peuvent le caractère
humanitaire de leur mission ce sera
d'ailleurs le point clé des plaidoiries
de leurs avocats prévu après demain deux
journalistes français risquent la peine
de mort au niger ils viennent d'être
inculpés pour intelligente
l'intelligence avec des bandes armées
thomas dandois pierre creisson et leur
chauffeur ont été arrêtés alors qu'ils
tentaient de réaliser pour la chaîne
arte un reportage sans autorisation sur
la rébellion touareg dans le nord du
pays
c'est un appel à la fois poignant et
troublant les parents de la petite
maddie qui je vous le rappelle sont
mises en examen dans la disparition de
leur fille au portugal en mai dernier
ont décidé de lui envoyer un message de
noël
le fonds est touchant mais la forme peut
surprendre correspondance à londres
arnaud gut et dominique marault tél
notre unique veut pour noël ces capsules
nous reviennent nous prions pour cela le
message face caméra et émouvant le film
de famille qui l'accompagnent tout
autant on peut voir m'a dit il ya tout
juste un an
découvrant ces cadeaux et notamment ce
petit sac rose que la fillette avait
avec elle au portugal dans ce même salon
sa mère peine à retenir ses larmes
c'est papa et maman
nous t'aimons tu nous manques chez soi
courageuse ma chérie puis c'est aux
éventuels ravisseurs qu'elle s'adresse
hymne sunstein vous devez comprendre que
vous seuls d'étonner lactée qui peut
mettre fin à notre désespoir et à notre
angoisse
les époux affirme que leur fille a
disparu le 3 mai lorsqu'elle dormait
dans un appartement au sud du portugal
soupçonné ils ont été mises en examen
par la police portugaise mais depuis
septembre vif chez eux en angleterre
l'enquète n'avance pas et une campagne
mobilise des personnalités comme le
footballeur david beckham
les très catholiques mccann ont souvent
répété qu'il souhaitait voir leur fille
à noël aujourd'hui ils ne cachent pas
leur tristesse baisse à une période
aussi particulière de l'année où toutes
les familles se retrouvent c'est
habituellement un moment de bonheur
surtout pour les enfants
mais pour nous cela va être le noël le
plus dur car matinée pas là malgré cet
appel de noël une question se pose
combien de temps encore les mc cain
pourront ils financer la recherche de
maddie
car malgré le coup de pouce de quelques
grandes fortunes et bien les dons de
particuliers se font rares et cela
depuis la mise en examen des parents de
la fillette
c'est ce qui s'appelle un voyage éclair
voyage surprise aussi pour des raisons
de sécurité nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu
aujourd'hui en afghanistan pour quelques
heures seulement
au programme visite des troupes
françaises présentes sur place et
soutien aux autorités locales
reportage de michaël darmon qui a pu
suivre le président dans son déplacement
deux mirage français
hess corp l'airbus présidentiel
pas sur les principales mesures dont
nous traînons dan monsieur nous allons
nous poser toutes les instances sur le
vote report de la poule nicolas sarkozy
en visite éclair en afghanistan un
déplacement tenu secret par l'elysée
jusqu'au dernier moment
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république est à kaboul
première étape donc diplomatiques avec
le président hamid karzaï
il évoque la reconstruction de l'état
afghan mais l'objectif du voyage et
militaires sur cette base aux forces de
kaboul les soldats français entre l
armée afghane
ça progresse à monsieur le président
doucement un rythme lent mais ça
progresse et ça va dans le bon sens ça
veut dire qu'il faut encore combien de
temps il faudra du temps monsieur le
président d'abord réticent sur le sujet
nicolas sarkozy pense à renforcer
l'équipe française en afghanistan
il s'agit que l'afghanistan ne devienne
pas un état qui tombe aux mains des
terroristes comme nous l'avons vu avec
les talibans dont qui se joue ici une
guerre une guerre contre le terrorisme
contre le fanatisme que nous pouvons et
que nous devons pas perdre cette visite
à nicolas sarkozy à cabourg s'inscrit
dans un tempo diplomatiques washington
attendait un geste de la france pour
montrer son implication dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les talibans
en cette période de fêtes les proches et
les soutiens d'ingrid betancourt ne
veulent pas oublier la
franco-colombienne
ce soir quelques 250 personnes se sont
réunies devant la cathédrale notre dame
à paris
chacune d'entre elles a déposé une
bougie
symbole de l'espoir voyons maintenant où
nous en sommes de la situation des trois
otages qui peuvent être libérés par la
guérilla colombienne parmi et vous le
savez dit à l'assistance
ingrid betancourt clara rojas ainsi que
son fils est un ancien parlementaire
ils doivent être remis au président du
venezuela voisin hugo chavez
ce dernier s'apprête donc à les recevoir
et à les accueillir sur place à caracas
renaud bernard frank dressées derrière
la nonchalance de l'hiver tropicale
caracas attend le retour de son
président hugo chavez détient la clé de
la libération des otages mais pour le
moment il est toujours à cuba le pays
prépare l'opération nous dit ce kiosque
y est mais le président a dit que la
tâche sera compliquée il faut sécuriser
la zone où les farc vont remettre leurs
otages l'important explique la voix
officielle du gouvernement vénézuélien
et d'empêcher le gouvernement colombien
de faire dérailler l'opération pour les
farc la sécurité des otages est un enjeu
énorme
ils doivent les libérer sans que les
ennemis n'est la possibilité de lancer
une opération armée contre eux le lieu
de la libération et stratégique
primordial aussi l'état de santé de
clara rojas de son fils de 3 ans et de
la parlementaire consuelo gonzalez à
caracas
des équipes médicales sont prêtes les
otages seront pris en charge par des
infirmiers et des psychologues pour les
otages c'est très dur psychologiquement
l'incertitude est la pire des situations
jusqu'au dernier moment ils vont douter
de leur libération
et puis il y a les conséquences
psychologiques très lourde d'une longue
détention dans la jungle
on ne sait ni où ni quand cette
libération va intervenir mais les farc
le président hugo chavez et le
gouvernement colombien répète qu'il
souhaite que les otages soient dans leur
famille pour noël noël un exercice pas
toujours facile lorsqu'on est candidat à
la présidentielle aux états unis tous
les prétendants se sont fendus cette
année d'un petit clip pour les voeux
chacun dans son style on en retiendra un
en particulier celui du demos des
démocrates barack obama
dans son camp il n'est pas forcément le
mieux placé en termes de voix pour
l'investiture mais tous les sondages
nationaux le donnent en tête pour battre
les rivaux républicains potentiels
correspondance alain de chalvron
margerie gratte les américains n'ont pas
encore élu leur nouveau président mais
ils ont déjà leur dinde le candidat qui
a fait la plus grosse bévue dans ce pays
vous pouvez partir de rien et vous
offrir une coupe de cheveux à 300 euros
pas mal hein effectivement lorsqu'on se
présente comme le candidat des classes
populaires et laborieuse et c'est
précisément le message que tente de
faire passer john edwards numéro trois
dans les sondages et les démocrates
son rival barack obama a droit lui au
titre plus enviable de meilleur danseur
ailleurs higuain de bastad et le
meilleur dans ça pour le moment
oui mais le niveau est bien faible
hillary clinton n'a été jugé trop guindé
c'est son problème et elle le sait bien
se rendre plus humaine
elle fait appel à sa mère et sa fille
dans ses pubs de campagne une campagne
en difficulté les derniers sondages
indiquent qu'elle serait battu par
presque tous les candidats républicains
tandis que barack obama les batteries de
tous sans exception
il battrait en particulier rudi giuliani
qui n'est pourtant pas mauvais danseur
non plus
l'ancien maire de new york est lui aussi
en difficulté
talonné comme favori des républicains
par mike huckabee ex gouverneur de
l'arkansas et ancien pasteur qui place
sa campagne sous le signe de la croix ce
qui compte vraiment c'est la naissance
du christ avec la complicité du père
noël ou de leur petite famille certains
semblent appeler à une trêve des
confiseurs peu de chance ne soit entendu
imaginez une région grande comme 24 fois
la france mais peuplé seulement de 40
millions d'habitants
on va maintenant partir en sibérie avec
ce reportage surprenant nos envoyés
spéciaux laurent bouffier et xavier
musée ils ont suivi le chemin d'un train
hôpital un train qui sillonnent le grand
nord russe pour répondre aux besoins des
populations
il faut dire que depuis la chute de
l'urss le système de santé est devenue
quasi inexistant dans ces provinces
c'est notre grand format de ce soir
le train roule depuis 24 heures sans
qu'on sent toujours plus dans le désert
glacé du grand nord russe à bord douze
médecins six infirmières et surtout un
matériel des plus modernes au standard
des meilleurs hôpitaux européens
ce train a été conçu pour offrir une
médecine de qualité avec des
technologies modernes dans ces régions
totalement isolé blanc rouge bleu ce
train est reconnaissable entre mille
première étape d'une tournée de 16 jours
un minuscule village perdu au milieu de
la taïga ici c'est le désert médical le
train vient une fois par an et on sait
soigner une fois par an aleph tina à 83
ans c'est la première fois qu'elle voie
un médecin
depuis des mois j'ai mal partout mais
après j'ai mal au dos je suis leur
esclave réception enregistrement tout
est conçu comme dans une clinique
médecine générale cardiologie
gynécologie ophtalmologie très vite
toutes les infirmières tous les médecins
sont occupés
avancez le pied fermez les yeux
on est là parce que vous sentez une
différence quand ces villages sont très
isolés les jeunes médecins refusent de
venir s'installer
c'est pour ça que la santé des gens se
dégrade
c'est leur compte dans ces villages où
fin décembre les journées durent moins
de trois heures et où la température
dépasse rarement -25 une maison sur deux
est abandonné moyenne d'âge de la
population 60 ans pour boris comme pour
les autres cet hôpital sur rails
c'est la surface et vida manque c'est
bien l'année dernière j'ai eu une
attaque cérébrale son jeu j'étais foutu
15 heures la nuit tombe
à bord les consultations vont se
poursuivre encore longtemps ce n'est que
beaucoup plus tard en fin de soirée que
le train va reprendre sa route vers le
nord
à l'extérieur la tempête de neige fait
rage à l'intérieur alors que l'équipage
technique prépare la nuit médecins et
infirmières rejoignent leurs cabines
quand le jour se lève
le convoi stationnent aux abords d'une
petite ville de 30 mille habitants ici
il y à bien un hôpital et quelques
médecins mais tout est tellement vétuste
que les malades préfèrent encore
attendre le train d'abord la réunion du
matin n'est pas encore terminée que déjà
c'est l'affluence
andy rihs aventis et son matériel
destiné aux escales étaient plus de 120
patients seront reçus ce jour là pour
l'équipe médicale
la routine une seule vies humaines
sauvées
ça justifie l'existence de ce trafic web
store
chaque mois ce train effectué entre 15
et 18 jours de mission un îlot de
modernité pour soulager les souffrances
dans des régions en voie de
désertification et c'est justement ce
ibérique était tombé le dernier
astéroïde grands comme celui qui menace
actuellement la planète mars demi de
1908 par dont 2800 ans exactement après
la nasa surveille de très près un énorme
caillou céleste et selon ses calculs il
pour répercuter la planète rouge le crom
janvier prochain josé devant lapierre
vitesse 13 km seconde dimension 50 m de
diamètre une sorte d'énorme rocher se
dirige vers m'a découvert en novembre
par la nasa
l'astéroïde pour répercuter la planète
rouge
le 30 janvier si la collision a lieu se
produira un énorme tremblement de terre
l'équivalent d'une bombe atomique
l'impact pourrait former un cratère de 1
km de diamètre
un peu comme en sibérie en 1908
lorsqu'un objet céleste mystérieux
encore aujourd'hui avait détruit des
millions d'arbres sur deux mille
kilomètres carrés
mais si l'astéroïde évite mars sa
trajectoire le rapprochera de la terre
il pourrait se produire alors le même
scénario qu'il ya 65 millions d'années
le chaos la fin des dinosaures mais ce
n'est pas pour demain
plutôt encore du domaine de la fiction
et après l'astéroïde aussi l'étoile miss
france 2008 étoiles peut-être finances
c'est en tout cas ce que souhaiterait
madame de fontenay qui a réclamé sa
démission la dame au chapeau a bien
failli le manger en découvrant des
photos de la nouvelle élue qu'elle juge
trop suggestives à la réunion revanche
dans l'île natale de la miss on n'est
pas du tout cet avis et même l'évêque
local vient de lui donner sa bénédiction
pierre menez gier voici les photos qui
risque de coûter son trône à miss france
les clichés ont été publiées par le
magazine entrevue pas de nudité mais des
poses lascives qui ne sont pas du tout
du goût de l'achat promis
ce n'est pas l'image d'une mise éclair
comme celle en deux pieds sur une croix
en train de lécher sais pas quoi bon
c'est pas d'image des migrants c'est
tout la réunionnaise de 22 ans qui
venait d'être accueillis en princesse
sur son île natale parle d'une erreur de
jeunesse
c'est peut-être ce ne serait pas c'est
des photos strictement privé je n'ai
jamais été rémunéré lui pose devant qui
il n'y a pas eu de contrat c'était des
photos personnelles
une version confirmée par la chaîne de
vêtements qui avait commandé les photos
il s'agissait simplement d'un essai
réalisé plusieurs années avant son
élection
une pétition a été lancée sur internet
en soutien à valérie bègue les
réunionnais qui n'ont pas eu de miss
france depuis 30 ans refuse de perdre
leur règne je vois pas pourquoi ils
viendront lui et il vient de revenus et
les choses maintenant alors qu elle
était élue alors tout était fait dans
les normes des caquettes photo ag via
pas des prix d'achat mais l'univers des
miss est sans pitié candidat s'il ya un
jour pris des poses provocantes doit
remettre sa couronne à sa dauphine en
l'occurrence miss nouvelle calédonie pas
facile de trouver un jouet lorsque tous
les enfants réclament le même en même
temps sur certains produits le père noël
semble déjà en rupture de stock et en
particulier pour les consoles de jeux
par exemple
apprêtez-vous à en consoler certains les
bases issa mahdi diawara si d'un côté
les enfants disent oui à tous les objets
certains magasins eux répondent non
faute de stocks
le père noël doit résoudre un terrible
casse-tête apporte l objet de rêve et
faire plaisir à tout le monde en même
temps ici l'un des jouets vedette c'est
le pet shop des petits animaux en
plastique
hier y en avait plus on a eu une
livraison ce matin et d'ici ce soir il y
en aura certainement plus jusqu'à la
nouvelle livraison qui peut être
arrivera lundi
pas touche le chat la collection de
spiderman ou ce drôle d'éléphants ne
font que des apparitions momentanée dans
les magasins certains tentent leur
chance plusieurs fois j'ai passé la
semaine dernière j'ai trouvé mais les
grands absents des rayons sont les
consoles de jeux électroniques
il ne reste souvent que des boîtes vides
de démonstration hier marc quelques unes
sont partis en un quart d'heure vingt
minutes qu en attendant les
représentants de nintendo en france
savourent leur succès la capacité de
production a été multipliée par deux
pour atteindre 1 million 800 mille
consoles par mois et pourtant tous ses
stocks ont eu et ont été mangés on n'a
pas pu ce surstock et pour la fin de
l'année donc on est vraiment obligé de
effectivement l'approvisionner en flux
tendu les entrepôts les magasins est
donc sacré quelques quelques petites
tensions pour le moment joué et magasins
sont à la fête
en attendant le tour des enfants
contrairement aux prévisions la
situation sur les routes a finalement
été plutôt bonnes en ce jour de grand
départ tout le monde est arrivé en temps
et en heure et pour ceux qui sont partis
à la neige ces bonnes pioches cette
année elle est au rendez vous y compris
dans les stations où elle avait manqué
cruellement l'an dernier reportage à
super besse en auvergne virgin est fiché
olivier jacque là à l'heure où blanchit
la montagne les skieurs sont
irrésistiblement attiré par les sommets
80 cm de neige en haut des pistes
à peine arrivés les plus impatients
chose déjà les spatules
on vient de la charente alors ça se
passe super bien la neige est au rendez
vous c'est génial
en bas la ruche s'animent peu à peu les
vacanciers arrivent au compte goutte et
prennent leurs marques
on est arrivé ce matin on a fait les
lits on a tous déplier et maintenant on
va skier
d'autres préfèrent prendre leur temps et
apprécier leurs premières neiges à super
besse les hôtels et appartements
affichent des taux de réservation proche
de 80%
la clientèle vient essentiellement du
nord et de l'ouest de la france elle est
fidèle mais cette année elle modifie
quelque peu ses habitudes
soit les gens viennent avant le
réveillon de noël soit ils viennent
entre les réveillons pour garder leur
réveillon en famille ou avec les copains
ou alors vous allez les gens qui
viennent au réveillon et dont ils
viennent trois jours particulièrement
touchées l'an dernier par le manque de
neige le domaine de ski de fond a lui
aussi retrouvé sa blancheur et cette
année pas question de laisser fondre ce
capital inespérée de début de saison que
j'ai stocké de la neige les embrouilles
critique parce qu'on sait que c'est
toujours au même endroit qu'on a des
difficultés à stopper la neige donc
cette année on a prévu en eau stockée de
la neige
cerise sur la bûche il y aura même de la
neige à noël les prochains flocons sont
en effet annoncé mardi 25 décembre
le dieu du foot perd une place sur le
lin des personnalités préférées des
français zinedine zidane est passée à la
deuxième position derrière le chanteur
yannick noah pour ce dernier classement
biannuel de nos confrères du journal du
dimanche et puis on notera l'entrée en
force de rugbyman chabal chabal comme
disent les commentateurs sportifs
le barbu des stades des propulsé
directement à la 35e place à niveau
classement revanche pour nancy et lyon
en football lyon numéro un n'a pas
dévorer son petit poursuivant les
nancéens ont réussi à égaliser à un
partout dans les dernières minutes
c'était cet après midi dans un froid
glacial
florent gautreau si lyon n'a pas perdu
ce soir il le doit à cet homme à rémy
vercoutre explosif décisif et chanceux
sur cette tête de fortune et le ballon
de l'attaquant de nancy touche le poteau
et le nez du gardien lyonnais
c'est le début d'une guirlande
d'occasions pour celles aura un
surprenant qu'ils auront tiré 24 fois au
but contre cette fois seulement côté
lyonnais mais en deuxième période
l'infortuné fortunés trouver encore
vercoutre sur sa route
même chose pour hadji quelques minutes
plus tard nancy domine nancy s'enflammer
oublient de défendre à dix minutes de la
fin c'est le contre lyonnais
l'heure du réalisme a sonné mylan barros
ouvre le score et offre à cet instant
sept points d'avancé à son équipe en
tête du championnat
injuste pour les nancéens qui repartent
à l'attaqué 87e minute malonga égalise
sa reprise de volée déviée par un
défenseur lyonnais trompe vercoutre le
gardien du temple lyonnais a cédé pour
la plus grande joie de son collègue d'en
face lyon conserve toutefois quatre
points d'avancé sur son dauphin en serre
en ces périodes de fêtes on va parler du
chocolat maintenant ni le risque fort
d'être de plus en plus amère non pas
pour le palais mais pour le portefeuille
les prix sont appelés à suivre ceux des
matières premières notamment du cacao et
vous allez voir que pour les
chocolatiers ce n'est pas sur la main
d'oeuvre que l'on peut rogner si l'on
veut faire un produit de qualité
sophie brune tristan lebrasse ici même
les tabliers ont la couleur du chocolat
pour préparer les fêtes ces salariés
travaillent d'arrache-pied plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de chocolats sont
produits chaque jour noël représentent
30% des ventes de l'année
tous les lots elle soufflé notre
profession m'avait dit je travaille
énormément de commandes
voilà on est on est à fond dedans le
chocolat coule à flots mais le processus
de production est restée artisanale les
décorations par exemple sont toutes
faites à la main c'est à la main
également que la matière première et
cassis pour toutes les recettes deux
ingrédients sont indispensables les
ingrédients de base pour une ganache
c'est d'abord le chocolat grand cru
ensuite de l'axone faibli et
éventuellement incluse avec des épices
du désert de frêche
vraiment un spécialiste qui doit
réaliser ça mélangé remuer agitée cette
base est ensuite étalé et refroidi sur
ses plaques de marbre mais loin d'être
lisse et le prix du chocolat a augmenté
cette année sur les crème le beurre le
lait et hausse de 15 à 20 % donc sur les
cours du cacao
beyrouth - porter 2007 et prend le mans
des hausses importantes sur deux v8 à
venir le chocolat va-t-il alors devenir
un produit de luxe est presque déjà le
cas dans cette boutique où les 100
grammes coûte un peu moins de 10 euros
mais ce ne sont pas les matières
premières qui explique le prix de ces
gourmandises haut de gan
on est sur un métier et beaucoup de
compétences manuelles et au quelqu'un
l'impact des massifs des matières
premières est moins fort en fait sur le
prix fini c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous n'avons pas pratiqué ces deux
chaînes pas de hausse pour l'instant
mais si le cacao continue à flamber des
augmentations sont à prévoir au cours de
l'année prochaine autre idée cadeau ce
n'est pas du chocolat ce n'est pas
forcément non plus une tarte à la crème
si vous savez le choisir le coffret de
musique classique revient en force cette
année et l'offre est si importante que
le père noël lui-même semble avoir du
mal à s'y retrouver
alors nous avons décidé de le guider
dans ses choix françois jullien
pieds-noirs valérie lucas
ce fut une partition bien difficile à
déchiffrer pour le père noël
il y avait tant d'heures de musique à
écouter et des kilos de coffrets à
porter car la mode cette année c'est
d'avoir tout to back ou tout chopin
beethoven par exemple est enfermé dans
cette boîte de 100 cd
il vous faudrait six jours non-stop pour
tout écouter
et si vous n'en avez pas assez enchaîné
vous les 50 plus grands opéras du monde
où le coffret des prestigieuses éditions
harmonia mundi qui fête ses 50 ans des
centaines de cd à moins de 100 euros ou
au le père noël ne voulait surtout pas
se faire arnaquer sur la qualité il a
donc pris rendez vous avec un homme de
musique pour comprendre le pourquoi de
ces petits prix suivant les éditeurs
soient en fait appel un fonds de
catalogue qui a déjà été amortis soit on
va chercher des interprètes moins connus
qui coûte moins cher soit on enregistre
avec des orchestres étrangers qui sont
d'excellente qualité mais ces artistes
sont de grands artistes aussi la
tendance cette année c'est aussi de nous
initier au monde parfois un peu élitiste
de la musique classique
et oui on se trouve parfois un peu nu le
musicologue jean françois zygel l'a bien
compris il sort en dvd ses émissions de
rôle et pédagogique pour comprendre la
musique de mendelson ou de bach
normalement quand on joue du bach on
joue bien on pourrait rater bannissement
j'entends jean et le père noël a aussi
pensé aux petits mélomanes écoutez
valérie lemercier nous conter pierre et
le loup de prokofiev pierre ne fit aucun
cas des paroles de son grand-père et
déclara que les grands garçons comme lui
n'avait pas peur d idéal pour réussir un
enfant ça peut lui donner après envie de
faire un instrument de commencer un
instrument et puis on envie moi je me
souviens quand j'étais petit j'avais
envie de jouer les oeuvres que
j'entendais évidemment dans ses disques
le marché du disque classique d'ailleurs
se porte plutôt mieux que celui des
autres musiques
c'est peut-être grâce au marketing du
père noël qui a toujours su renouveler
tous et à coeur
chose promise chose due hier soir henri
salvador vous a offert ses adieux à la
scène juste avant son dernier concert à
paris et bien comme prévu l'émotion
était au rendez-vous en voici les
meilleurs extraits olivier les nz à
mathieu guerbert réussir ses adieux
la sonnerie retentit
le rideau va s'ouvrir pour la dernière
fois
mais dis donc je le vois il pourrait se
sent pas la gnagna 3000 spectateurs
anonymes zehani entre autres michel
jonasz venu je l'aimais et je reconnais
avoir les amis
c'est un des plus grands artistes
français et en plus beaucoup d'affection
pour l'eau c'est la vie il faut c'est la
vie wada région et la vie en chansons 75
ans de carrière pendant arrêté jusqu'à
cet ultime concert
j'y pensais jamais et quand ça arrive
c'est effrayant
avant que ma jeunesse
et que mes printemps soit parti
sans voir syracuse
pendant 90 minutes les souvenirs
défilent bonsoir je largue les amarres
si je suis parmi vous arrive le moment
de se séparer mais qu il exerçait la
kippa michel botte
messi a livré devant quitter de l'usaid
c'est comme ça
ouais
this is a really ministère
la motion
il est sur scène il entend derrière le
rideau le public
il s'en va puis soudain
il s'en retourne comme pour arrêter le
temps goûter encore ce qui fit toute sa
vie les applaudissements du public
c'est la fin de ce journal merci d'avoir
suivi vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres
il sera décidément difficile pour les
parisiens qui ont choisi l'avion de
rejoindre leur famille en région la
grève à air france se poursuivra demain
à orly ouest
la compagnie affirme cependant qu'elle
pourra assurer 80% du trafic
aujourd'hui elle a dû annuler près d'un
tiers de ses vols intérieurs à noter que
la corse et les antilles ne sont pas si
c'est par ce mouvement
c'est tout pour l'actualité de ce samedi
tout de suite la météo laurent romejko à
20h50 vous avez rendez vous avec patrick
sébastien pour les années bonheur et
puis pour ma part je vous dis à demain
dès 13h excellent tu arrêtes sur france
l'info en continu ses positions trousses
de point fr
oui